Joker before we let you go um we would
be remiss if we did not allow Shaq to
speak to you in your native tongue my
gosh I just want to say let go sh I just
want to say brother Volente Volente
Volente good job good job sh I like the
suit really good did he say what did he
say says I love you I love you good J
fall Day fall day
[Applause]
time next time something different next
time different come on we give him
plenty of time to prepare Nico thanks
man we appreciate you guys speak all the
[Music]
languages
guys hey
Ernie oh my God you know you were asking
what Shaq was talking about his game he
going to be able to play longer longer
greater because he doesn't play with
crazy athletic ability now he going to
be able to play great for longer think
about what he did say though which is a
misconception oh I didn't take many days
off no but I'm saying he he don't play
Above the Rim he going to be able to
play longer yes sir at a high level